meetic et nicolas hulot n'est pas homme
à se précipiter dans l'arène politique
comme cela en 2007 déjà il s'était posé
la question
y aller ou pas finalement la
présidentielle s'était déroulée sans lui
alors quand celui ci annonce hier qu'il
s'interroge désormais pour 2012
c'est toute la galaxie europe ecologie
les verts qui tous s'interrogent même si
certains s'enthousiasme il faut rappeler
que nicolas hulot est toujours aussi
populaire avec plus de 80% d'opinions
favorables dans le dernier baromètre
ifop paris match
nos équipes l'ont rencontré aujourd'hui
reportage alexandre kara jean-marie
lequertier et mathias barrois
aujourd'hui nicolas hulot n'était
toujours candidat à rien juste hésitant
difficile sans doute de ne pas penser à
lorsqu'on est la personnalité politique
préférée des français
si dans les deux trois mois qui viennent
j'ai j'ai pas l'intuition je leur ai
jamais moi je me dis que les gens dans
le carrefour de complexité aujourd'hui
qui rêve d'être au pouvoir soit ils sont
très courageuse qui probablement arriver
ou alors sont totalement inconscients
quoi emblème de l'écologie médiatique
nicolas hulot s'est bien gardé jusqu
alors de prendre la carte d'un parti
lorsqu'il joue les parrains d'europe
écologie les verts
c'est en ami un ami qui dérange pour les
écologistes il y a déjà une candidate
nommé eva joly pas tout à la fois dire
j'ai les réponses à la planète et dire
bah si c'est pas moi et si vous ne
souhaitez pas immédiatement eh ben je ne
viens pas donc non je dis très
tranquillement europe ecologie les verts
n'attendent pas le sauveur suprême ans
d'autant que nicolas hulot est un
récidiviste déjà en 2007 il avait mis un
pied dans la campagne présidentielle
un lobbying intense et efficace au final
les principaux candidats avaient signé
son pacte écologique
il est utile à l'écologie comme force de
pression en n'étant pas candidat et en
obligeant les autres les autres
politiques ceux qui sont vraies on
seront réellement candidats à prendre
des positions avancées sur les thèmes de
l'environnement qui de bluff ou
véritable réflexion
les hésitations de monsieur hulot risque
de diviser encore un peu plus europe
ecologie les verts